some 200,000 seafarers are stuck on
ships because of the covert 19 pandemic
according to the International transport
workers Federation they're not allowed
to leave their vessels because of
international travel restrictions and
it's hard for replacement crews to come
and relieve them thousands of sailors
don't have access to health
professionals experts are warning the
situation could become life-threatening
for many heart attacks and suicides have
already been reported aboard some ships
[Music]
welcome to your covert 19 special on DW
news I'm Monica Jones good to have you
with us now the movement of goods around
the world depends on them but now
they're unable to move themselves on
today's show we're talking about what it
means for seafarers to be stranded
aboard because of a pandemic not knowing
when they can return home
our reporter Christina who visited a
ship that's been allowed to dock in a
northern German port but it's crew
aren't allowed any further a few hours
ago the golden Empress moored in the
German port city of Hamburg Ola Florida
from the German Siemens mission is
coming on board today he's bringing a
few things to the sailors who can't
leave the ship the port of Hamburg
itself has been allowing shore leave
again but the captain on this ship has
decided against it and the crew is
backing him up
but it's okay for our safety reason
because we'll murder this pandemic Kobe
19 that's why we stay on board we will
not go sure we want to go outside you
know gonna go some places but because of
Karuna
we cannot go outside the ship will be
docked there for two days unloading iron
ore it's a time when those on board have
a better phone connection for calling
home and better internet than on the
high seas that's why the seamen's
mission is bringing the sailors German
SIM cards for their cell phones
Ola Florida just sold a dozen of them
and he has a sympathetic ear for the
problems the sailors are facing if the
virus made its way on board then in the
worst case scenario it would mean that
the ship would have to stay in the
harbor it wouldn't be allowed to leave
and you couldn't even switch out crews
because you'd never find a new crew
anyway before the corona virus pandemic
many sailors frequented the Hamburg
seaman's club here they could make free
phone calls or transfer money to their
families but since the pandemic it's
mostly empty mark she'll vote on T is
the exception his captain gave him
permission to leave the ship for an hour
so that he could wire his family some
urgently needed money he wouldn't have
left the ship for any other reason for
me is better stay in the ship and stay
away for the people for a while we're
waiting for we are waiting for crew
change some day but it's difficult but
the more we are here on ship the more
money that we have members of another
crew have been given permission to leave
their ship without any restrictions and
come here for a few hours
the rooms are well ventilated still they
keep to themselves so that they can
enjoy their free time without fear of
catching the virus after the money has
been transferred to his family mark Jill
Volante quickly buys a few things at the
seamen's mission shop
they stop the items that sailors are
always asking for souvenirs toothpaste
and sweets and pork chunks which are
pork flavored chips popular among the
sailors the ones that are allowed to
come here rejoice like it's Christmas
they come in they're beaming they're so
happy to come inside they enjoy being
here even if it's only for an hour if it
weren't for the coronavirus crisis the
seamen's mission in Hamburg would be
filled to capacity but these days
sailors like Mark Shaw of allanté and
his colleague just take the shuttle bus
directly back to their ship
after this visit to Hamburg they don't
know where or when they'll be on land
again for more I'm joined by my
esophagus house and good from the
International transport workers
Federation good to have you with us our
report to just show to the situation for
seafarers here in Germany is it the same
elsewhere alright even worse actually
around the world because I mean most of
the European countries they have
recognized seafarers as key workers but
that's rather exceptional if I look at
the global perspective so for example if
I look at the global seafaring market
it's around 400 seafarers worldwide that
are waiting to leave the vessel or water
join the vessel so it's it's quite um
it's quite a tight situation right and
is there a difference in terms of
working on a container ship or a cruise
liner for seafarers right now we're in a
way yeah does there's a difference I
mean so the duties on the vessel they
differ a way and it's even different if
I look at the perspective the Seafarer
self so if I'm working on a cruise
vessel at the moment and cruise resumes
and I'm mostly laid up so it's rather a
question of how can I get home but if
I'm working on a container vessel it's
even worse because it's a question of
when I can get home and when there is
somebody and to substitute me because
working on a container of us that I can
only leave if there are somebody else
that can join the vessel and that's
really a problematic situation at the
moment because as governments are
closing their borders and flights global
flights are rather restrict it it's
rather complicated to be at the white
spot at the white moment in order to
facilitate the crew change right I mean
keeping a sailor seafarers on board is
also to protect them from eventually
catching of the virus when they go on
land but what happens despite all the
safety measures if the virus actually
gets on board well this depends very
much on the company policy and the local
requirements so um for example I've been
in contact with vessels that have caught
the virus here in a German port and
those vessels need to stay
in port unless everybody got tested
negative and then they could leave other
things that you can get to seafarers of
the vessel and substitute them by other
seafarers but as I already mentioned and
crew change is really a big issue at the
moment it's not easy to get seafarers
from the vessel so it's quite a problem
it's it's tiny but the good yeah the
good it's really tough but the good
thing is it's um the number of vessels
that have caught the virus are so low so
it's quite quite a good situation but
there are there are other threats as
we've also heard threats of seafarers
getting heart attacks and so forth why
is that mm-hmm it's it's a tough
situation at the moment I mean if you if
you imagine being a Seafarer working
about the vessel I mean you you live in
kind of eight to ten square meters cabin
you see the same wall every day you're
working on the same in the same
environment seeing for example the
engine room day in day out for 12 months
in a row working every day seven days a
week so it's really tough situation and
usually those seafarers I mean they
already joined the vessel and they know
when there's already they have to kind
of return flight ticket and then when
they join the Leicester so they know
when they will see their family again
but that is that is a real lockdown
situation much worse than anything that
we've experienced of course just briefly
what could solve the dilemma for them
we need governments to act we react not
just holding speeches and pretending to
do something so there were there were
some countries that have changed their
their status that have recognised
seafarers as key workers and they are
free and giving visas but it's really a
small number and we need more
governments to act so to open their
borders to issue visas and not to close
the borders all right well my good from
the international transport workers
Federation thank you so much for your
time thank you and now it's time for
more of your questions over to our
science correspondent Derek Williams
for how many days are asymptomatic
people contagious this is one of the
questions that medical professionals
would love an answer to but it's pretty
complex and we haven't even nailed down
answers to two simpler related questions
like like what percentage of people who
get the disease can even be classified
as asymptomatic or or how infectious
they are you might remember last month
there was an uproar when a w-h-o
official appeared to say that there were
indications that asymptomatic people
very rarely passed on the disease to
others that was that was followed by a
lot of backtracking but maybe it helps
to look at what we do know one expert I
read on this said that transmission from
people with symptoms generally tails off
completely within eight days after the
onset of those symptoms and and he
thought it unlikely that an asymptomatic
person would be infectious for longer
than that that sounds plausible to me
but it doesn't constitute proof of read
meta medical opinions on survival rates
ninety nine point four percent survival
seems to be the most common percentage
rate I'm seeing is that accurate
calculating this number with with real
confidence is still impossible at the
moment because there are still too many
open variables the statistic you
mentioned probably originally comes from
the WH o--'s chief scientist who has
said that the organization believes that
that what's called the infection
fatality rate
or IFR is around 0.6% now the IFR is the
is the true proportion if you will of
infected people who will die from
catching a disease it's not the
proportion of people who tested positive
and later died which is known as the as
the case fatality rate that's of course
much higher if the WH o--'s gas on the
IFR is accurate though which is still a
pretty big if though the lesson1 than it
was a few months ago then it would mean
that statistically around six out of
every thousand people who catch kovat 19
will eventually die from it whether they
tested positive beforehand or not now
that doesn't sound like much but but but
point six percent of the world's
population is still close to 250 million
people
[Music]